so you had some time to read the basic
details of the question this is what
they give you this is what's given
really um these two things are I'm not
giving you anything these could be an he
almost almost this could be almost any
complex numbers given that their angles
can be well from negative PI to PI I
figure out the idea don't you yeah
that's right you've got a range there or
domain I guess you'd say of two pi which
means basically you your argument could
be anything right from negative PI which
is over here all the way to PI so I
could be facing in any direction that's
the argument what's the other piece of
official you need for a complex number
today where it is it's the modulus ah
that actually tells you a little more
about the modulus doesn't it both of
these numbers the boy just would be are
at the front wouldn't it right now
because there's nothing written that
means that you don't R is equal to one
okay so that's that's kind of important
right we might put both of these down
one said and what W they both one that
would become important later on okay
that's good okay what are this over this
what can we do with this now actually if
you read the question actually try to
nudge you in the right direction that's
nice isn't it
they say by considering the real and
imaginary parts oh this or otherwise
sure that one Z and W form the vertices
of an equilateral triangle in the arc
net diagram okay now why you doing this
thing well let's let's take that clue
right now want to not just in a
particular direction let's take a clue
and have a look at this thing by taking
the imaginary the real the imaginary
parts okay now we've actually been
giving an equation so I can do more than
just think about the imaginary part of
this if I think about the imaginary part
of this well these two things are in
cool do you agree this is three complex
numbers added together well that should
just be one complex number so I can find
out the imaginary part of the whole
thing
now even though it's a little bit weird
being out that way if you take the
imaginary part of this side you
imagine part of this side do you agree
yes because here it is after all just
another complex number it's just the one
at the origin so far so good haven't
done anything crazy right okay let's
keep going a little bit the imaginary
part of this so this is one big complex
number okay
when you add a complex number together
like for instance if you had on this guy
and this guy okay if you added this
together you'd get one big complex
number yeah it would be a plus C plus a
plus C plus B there's a rumba and IB
plus IB plus I if there's the imaginary
part okay
so when you think about the imaginary
part of the sum of all those things
together do you recognize that it's the
sum of the imaginary parts let me say
that again slowly the imaginary part of
the sum is the sum of the imaginary
parts does that make sense yeah so I can
actually take that over here I can say
the imaginary part of the sum is the sum
of this imaginary part and this
imaginary part and this imaginary part
you with me is that okay cool I can
write down the right-hand side what is
the imaginary part of zero zero isn't it
because imaginary is like up or down I
even the answer is nowhere so that's
zero okay good all right let's keep
going now that I'm sort of brokered this
apart I can take these one at a time
right the imaginary part of one I know
what this is as well it's also zero
because you can see where one is there
it is right there
so hasn't it up or down okay so imagine
a party ah okay right okay yeah you need
a couple extra steps even though that's
correct
what's the imaginary part is it I
actually know what it is I wrote it down
at the board there is right I sign Thea
and in the same way I know what the
imaginary part of W is it's I sign
okay so this is good this is good what
this means I'll write it like this is
that I sine alpha equals negative PI
sine theta yeah like I've just I just
subtracted that from both sides okay so
this is good this is progress this is
showing me a relationship between
remember how I started off saying oh
these guys are just like it could be
anyway here well now I know they can't
be anywhere wherever this number happens
to be well this guy's want B to be on
the exact opposite side of the real axis
right because one might be up in the
elbows down or vice versa are you happy
with that okay so far so good now I
heard someone say excellent this means
that Z and W are complex conjugates now
as it happens
Zeena W are complex conjugates but I
don't know that yet what do I need for
if I had a number like X plus iy what's
its kopecks what'd you get it's minus y
so I've got the minus I Y bit you can
see they match up like that simple but I
need the real pots to be the same okay
so how am I gonna reach for something
like that okay let's have a good like
it's what so well for us right oh look
the imaginary pie it just sort of fell
out well instead of doing the imaginary
part of both sides well let's go over
here and say what's the real part on
both sides okay so here we go okay now
in exactly the same way that I did
before the real part of a sum is the sum
of all the real parts individually okay
so I can write that down it's the real
part of this one the real part of this
one and the real part of that one yep
just like I did before I can work out
what the real part of the origin is it's
also zero it's just how far left all
right I so that's good and just like I
did before I can start to evaluate
everything but then I hit a snap
what's the repot one real pot is it plus
theta and the root part of w cos alpha
huh
now uh this is still true right it's
just still true but we were kind of
hoping and and this instinct turns out
to this intuition turns out to be
correct we were kind of hoping to find
these things to be equal to each other
okay so that we had the two same real
bits right I don't know I don't have
that but I do have this I'm just gonna
jot this down first this is true but
it's not exactly what I was looking for
it shows me that these two are related
in some integral way but it surely
doesn't show me that they're identical
and I don't know what else it can show
me right so I did what the question told
me to do I I did something with the
imaginary part I considered that I
considered the real part so I'm not
quite there now look back at the
question let's look back it says you've
got all of this information I've already
written down I've considered the real
imaginary parts I want to show that what
there's one and znw
form an equilateral triangle in the
Argand diagram okay now just just work
with me for a second okay where could Z
and W be where could they possibly be
okay now you know that Z and W are not
just anywhere right like they could be
facing in all kinds of different
directions but in terms of distance in
terms of modulus they are all they're
all on it we actually the name for this
particular thing right what's that
called it's the unit circle they're all
the circumference of the unit circle
right which means that I actually know
exactly where Xen MW have to be if one
is here and remember apparently they
form an equilateral triangle right
there's only well I mean there's two
different points so the two points have
to be in two particular spots where are
they going to be yeah well you can sort
of see it right you're like okay one
should be over here and one should be
over here right so it's a magnet
gives you this right if they're going to
be we know that these two are going to
be opposite like where else could you
position them the answers you compition
position than anywhere else now we knew
that because we could draw you could see
it because there had to be on the circle
they had to be on the circle and we
haven't used that fact yet like we
noticed it we noticed it but we haven't
used it